Avengers infinity war is less of a movie
than an onslaught on the census throwing
40 different characters from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe at the same threat in
an unprecedented crossover of so many
fan favorites jockeying for attention in
the fight against Thanos one unassuming
character Karen Gillan's nebula may
prove to be the most important of all
heads-up spoilers ahead when audiences
first became acquainted with gamora's
blue skinned black eyed adoptive sister
nebula in 2014's guardians of the galaxy
she seemed like little more than a minor
foil for the good guys by the end of the
2017 sequel nebula has reconciled with
her sister and she turns her murderous
tendencies towards her true enemy I will
hunt my father like a dog and I will
tear him apart slow by the time the
credits roll in infinity war nebula is
one of the lucky 50% of people left
standing and if the comics history is
anything to go by Thanos will have to
watch his back for her in the next
century
infinity war pulls most of its
inspiration from the 1991 six issue
series Infinity Gauntlet which similarly
pitches every Marvel Comics hero against
Thanos as he works to mess up the
universe in that story nebula is a
target of therosis torture kept barely
alive but Thanos his biggest mistake
turns out to be keeping her alive at all
in the comics
thanassis horrible disdain for her gives
her order motivation she needs to turn
the tide in an unexpected moment barely
clinging to life
nebula snatches a gauntlet from Thanos
his grasp while getting the goal net
away from the fan owes as a momentary
relief IV nebula become the most
annuitant being in the universe isn't
exactly ideal the power of the gauntlet
proves far too potent for her scarred
psyche to safety wield and then away
makes it even more dangerous
once nebula is in control of the
gauntlet the Marvel heroes actually team
up with Thanos to get it back from her
when the universe's remaining heroes
confront nebula she uses the properties
of the time gem to turn back the clock
24 hours resurrecting everyone who was
neutralized by Thanos his fateful snap
in the process she then moves to
consolidate power for herself creating a
new world order with her was ruler
fortunately she's slightly too insane to
wield the power of the Infinity Gauntlet
as effectively as Sano's was able to and
the heroes attack her in a mad dash for
it
the gauntlet ultimately ends up in the
of Adam warlock a character who was yet
to appear in the flesh in the MCU while
Adams ultimate victory likely won't
happen in 2019 s Avengers movie it is
possible that nebula could fulfill a
similar purpose in the movies as she
does in the comics introducing a chaotic
Hellerman that the heroes can use to
their advantage whether the infinity war
will end with everyone teaming up to
attack a super-powered nebula remains to
be seen but her history in the comics
means everyone should keep an eye on her
going forward and from a storytelling
standpoint she's got to be alive for a
reason right
the story of the gauntlet is just
getting started Marvel Studios is set to
take audiences on a journey with ant-man
and the wasp and early July 2018
introduced Captain Marvel in March 2019
and finally cap off the story of the
entitled fourth Avengers movie in may
2019 we can't wait
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out his cool stuff we know your
loved team
[Applause]
[Music]